hi there steve kaufman here um
i recently did a video where i talked
about how our emotions get in the way
of our language learning
that um you know even though we would
like to pronounce say something a
certain way i use the example of myself
learning portuguese and and
speaking with brazilian people and
hearing them
say bongia and because of my spanish i
just don't want to say bungie even
though that's how how it's said
uh you know that my wife doesn't want to
pronounce the th
in spanish
uh there's a number of things that
whether it be because of our culture or
because of whatever prejudices we may
have
or other emotional
sort of forms of resistance
these things get in the way of us simply
accepting the new language and just
going with it and flowing with it i
mentioned the example of my father who
always used to say nova scotia instead
of nova scotia because to him it just
seemed to make more sense that it be
pronounced like the original latin or
something that he wasn't going to say
nova scotia even though he heard it all
the time and this kind of stuff happens
regularly and um
there was a person who commented on that
video and said you know a lot of the
resistance the emotional resistance that
we have to different aspects of the
language that we're trying to learn
a lot of this is subconscious so how do
we
persuade our brains
not to resist emotionally
uh surely that's impossible sort of
thing was his question
and
so
i'm going to tackle that one
first of all i think we have to decide
whether or not we want to change
this emotional resistance
let's take an example i have a certain
way of learning a language it's based on
listening and reading
and
sort of discovering the language
naturally acquiring words getting a feel
for the language
if i'm confronted with a system that
asks me to
i was on a system the other day just to
see what the competition is doing
where they
uh
show you pictures and then give you
these little snippets of phrases then
they quickly turn around and give it to
you in english and ask you to
say it in the target language then they
have you dragging and dropping words
while you're doing something with word
order in other words there is this whole
pedagogical school of thought that says
that we have to get the student to do
something with the language respond
say something
move words around analyze
and i have a tremendous resistance to
this the minute i see that i'm out of
there i don't want it i don't want to
have to say anything until i've heard it
a lot until i've had a chance to absorb
it so this might in fact be an
irrational emotional reaction on my part
i don't know but i have no desire to
change it
so
there's no way there that i'm going to
change it because i'm quite comfortable
i enjoy doing it my way i'm not about to
change
however
there
let's take the case of the
brazilian pronunciation there i think my
reaction is much more irrational
and so how do we change
emotional resistance that we have
uh
to something
i think in many cases if i if i look at
immigrants here who never progress
beyond a certain level and say english
it's because they're not very motivated
or they want to kind of hang back in
their culture
so
you know how do they how do we get them
to change that well if they don't want
to change it you can't get them to
change it
but
uh if in fact at some level we want to
change
then i think it can be done and that's
where i want to bring in what i consider
a very interesting book on many levels
which i have mentioned before it's
called the mind and the brain
the mind and the brain by let me just
hold it up a little bit better here the
mind and the brain by basically jeffrey
schwartz and what this book does it
talks about people who have
obsessive-compulsive behavior
and obsessive-compulsive behavior
it describes a situation where people
feel they have to wash their hands every
five minutes or
i don't know they're afraid of snakes it
could be anything which becomes
obsessive and very often this is treated
with drugs
and jeffrey schwartz developed
an approach a treatment
which is essentially based on getting
the patient to recognize
that the neural network that is driving
him or her to wash their hands every
three minutes or do ever something else
that's obsessive
that that sort of exists objectively in
the brain
and that with enough determination
and with a series of exercises and
practice
that the
mind
of of the patient
the determination the will the willing
to willingness to recognize that this
this circuitry that causes this person
to behave in a certain way
exists objectively and is not
necessarily part of that person's
personality
or or it doesn't have to be part of his
or her behavior
so that once the person recognizes that
their mind can be apart from
this behavior
then they can start looking at ways that
the mind can influence the brain and
actually change those neural networks
change that behavior or as the person
commenting to my previous video
said that we have these emotional
resistances
and that they are subconscious but even
subconscious things in the brain if we
are determined to
we can actually influence them through
our determination
so
if we are resisting something
hanging back in our native culture
unwilling to basically let ourselves go
let's say we have the irrational fear of
making a mistake or creating a bad
impression
i mean to make
the the fear that we're going to make a
mistake is not irrational but the fear
that we will be somehow thought less
well of or that it somehow causes people
not to like us or any of these other
fears associated with making a mistake
are largely irrational and so we can
perhaps using some of the
the methodology that's described by
schwartz here influence our brain so
that we are less
concerned less uptight less afraid or
that we don't resist certain forms of
pronunciation or
certain structures
uh of the new language and then we just
you know wholeheartedly
take them up and make them make them
part of ourselves
so given that you want to make that
change at some level and that the brain
is resisting the mind in fact according
to jeffrey schwartz can overcome the
brain
and i also have mentioned before in a
video that
i had a little bit of experience of
something somewhat related to this
when i was a little boy my father could
wiggle his ears
and i wanted to be able to wiggle my
ears
and i would literally sit
for hours
just
telling myself you know wiggle the ears
and eventually i was able to cause
a neural network or some connection to
occur
in my brain
that i don't know if you can see this
but i can wiggle my ears especially i
think this one no it's this one here
that wiggles more
you probably can't see it but i can
assure you i can wiggle my ears and this
is something that i achieved through my
determination
the mind
influencing the brain
so
uh i think that that uh the the answer
to this question uh you know how do we
overcome these irrational fears that we
have or these emotional
forms of emotional resistance that we
have well if you read the book by
jeffrey schwartz
uh you will see that in fact our
determination which is sending some kind
of uh you know electric electrochemical
signals
through the neurons and i mean i don't
understand all that stuff but it can
affect
the behavior of the brain the mind can
influence the brain and that i think has
lots of significance for language
learning so that's my answer to that
person's question thank you for
listening